he's Colin Hanks the actor the show
third season is life in pieces also in
town to attend an award show for his
documentary Eagles of Death Metal which
is on HBO it was on HBO yeah yeah I'm
gonna ask you about that coming up in a
moment here and your big time sports fan
but as we mentioned in the amount ten
minutes ago we co-starred in House Bunny
yes were you aware that we co-starred in
Hell spawn oh I took it because I knew
it was going to be the Dan Patrick
vehicle yes yeah of course
yeah they said we need someone right
away can you please come and I said yes
I'll be there is will Dan be there they
said no so I asked for just a little bit
more money yeah but you were an affairs
his love interest I was yes yeah yeah
that was you were great
you're a great cop you remember my
scenes yes of course you do okay of
course the Santa Faris had no idea who I
was that doesn't surprise me but I
thought that now her then her future
husband is a big sports fan now her
ex-husband yeah so I didn't know if she
was a sports fan became one because of
him so I that's why I thought maybe she
might know who or she had seen some of
my earlier works well I've been a fan of
your work for a very long time both on
the screen both big and small thank you
thank you you're a great actor oh by the
way are you are you can you I'm gonna
find out how good an actor you're okay
can you wear a Dodger hat and act like
you really care because all the people
in Hollywood all these actors in
Hollywood that we see in a Dodger game
now those are those are some great
actors there yeah no I'm not gonna wear
that because you're a Giants fan because
I'm a I'm a San Francisco Giants fan a
hardcore San Francisco Giants fan the
only actor that I know that that does
wear this while his allegiance is to
another squad is is Stonestreet Eric
Stonestreet Kansas City Royals the
Kansas City Royals but he will rock a
Dodgers cap but I think that's just
because of its different leagues at
least I think that's probably what he's
telling himself whenever he puts it on
how important were sports when you were
growing up big I mean that for me sports
was kind of how I would
relate to the kids in the neighborhood
you know that I grew up in Sacramento my
dad lived in Los Angeles and so I would
sort of travel back and forth and when
we moved to Sacramento with my mom you
know I had been living in Los Angeles
but I was a little kid I didn't really
know that much about sports I wasn't
that and invested but as I got older you
know all my friends were Niners fans all
my friends were were Giants fans and so
I just sort of fell in with that group
and then hockey came around for me my
dad took me to my first hockey game in
88 before Gretzky and that then I was a
fanatic I mean I still am a huge huge
hockey fan and that was really the only
sort of allegiance that went southern so
it was all Northern California sports
and then the LA Kings and then
eventually the Sharks came around and I
couldn't really quite get on that
bandwagon but yes I mean sports are big
for me it's it's all it's like Rich
Eisen says it's the best reality show in
the world and if you teach anybody just
the the background it can make those
games really interesting have you ever
thought about a sports movie show
absolutely I mean I've done two short 34
30 s about sports I did one called the
anti mascot which is about a the crazy
crab mascot that the San Francisco
Giants had in the 80s and it was a
mascot that was designed to be hated and
it only lasted one year and then I did
another one called wall-e in the worm
the Amazing Adventures of walling in the
worm which is about this guy Wally blaze
who was the assistant the assistant
athletic trainer for the Chicago Bulls
during their run and he was basically
put in charge of babysitting Dennis
Rodman for two weeks while Rodman was on
physical rehab it was a page I was
reading Phil Jackson's books have you
ever read Phil Jackson's books yeah
they're fantastic they're so great I'm
not even a Lakers fan and I think
they're amazing and there was this one
little paragraph talking about this
kid that had to basically watch Rodman
for like two weeks while he was doing a
bunch of physical therapy while he was
hurt during their magic sort of season
the mid-season of the they won like 75
games 72 72 yeah peanut gallery just
1710 72 in center and so yeah Dennis had
sort of gravitated towards Wally and so
while he had to basically hang out with
them and party with him and do
everything that Dennis Rodman did
crossdress yeah yeah and and Phil
Jackson even pitched it in the book he
said it was like almost famous meets get
him to the Greek and I said that's right
there so we animated it and Dennis
Rodman has different colored hair in
every scene and it's yeah it's all there
online somewhere he's Colin Hanks the
show is life in pieces season 3
premiered last night on CBS and also in
town the documentary Eagles of Death
Metal when did you know your dad was
famous well I mean there's different
degrees you know I always sort of laugh
because everyone goes like what's it
like being related to a national
treasure I'm like well he wasn't really
much of a national treasure you know
during the bosom buddy days or Turner
and hooch or anything like that so you
know I think there's varying degrees you
know what I mean
so for me it's just sort of oh there's
certain like pre eras and postera
people make fun of your dad when he was
dressing I was a woman and was somebody
no not really
I think everyone was just sort of like
oh yeah that that's that's that's what
he does and I went yeah but there had to
be this moment where all of a sudden he
became the Jimmy Stewart of you know
yeah I mean around the time of like
Philadelphian Forrest Gump it it became
a totally different animal did people
treat you differently yeah to a degree
but I sort of ignore those people I tend
to not really sort of I try to just sort
of zone those people out a little bit
because it's it's you know you could
spend so much time and energy obsessing
about that kind of stuff and you'll
still be in the exact same place you
know it won't move you it doesn't move
the needle it will move you any further
so I just kind of zone out when it comes
to that what was the guest list like at
your wedding it was great I had Mike
back there and Jake Bergman and PJ knock
man all the big names the way yeah the
wedding was a was a little surreal but I
have also sort of known these people
that are friends of my parents for a
long time so I was sort of like I guess
I got to invite some of your friends too
and they're like yep so I do have this
one really great memory of Bruce
Springsteen what wha who was walking and
I was I was sitting in in this sort of
like seat where I had like it was like
we were in like a tent so I couldn't see
past a certain you know area on the left
or right and Bruce Springsteen is sort
of walking and when he's not on stage he
kind of walks slow you know and he just
is sort of walking and I'm like looking
at him I'm like wow
as Bruce Springsteen walking really slow
and he stops turns points at me and then
keeps watching everyone around me was
just like oh my tell me about life in
pieces season three yeah this family
this family short family yeah I mean
we're we have a lot of fun on the show
it's where we're really pretty lucky
it's four short stories every week and
it all follows different members of this
like three generations of the short
family and so it's like little short
films and it's it's they're really funny
and witty and quick that's like this
great combination between really funny
farce and like an animated show that's
not animated that's the best way I can
describe it it's just really quick and
and we have we have a lot of fun we got
a lot of great people on the show dan
back at all Betsy Brandt Zoe
lister-jones Dianne Wiest James Rowland
we have a lot of fun we end up laughing
more than we than working and kind of
not too dissimilar than
this place right here tougher to do are
you attracted more to comedy or drama
I'm attracted to anything that can hold
my interest for longer than you know a
few days for me it's like you know it's
is this it's a strange thing to sort of
to explain but if I can't if I can't be
invested in something for a very long
amount of time and in the case of this
television show like three years yeah if
I'm not invested in that how on earth
can I go on national television and tell
people to be invested in it for 22
minutes you know so for me there was
just something about the writing of the
show and how funny it was the stories
that it was telling and and because of
our structure the way that it was
structured was just so fresh and so
different from everything else that I
said that that that seems like a worthy
endeavor the show is life and pieces it
premiered last night on CBS the
documentary that you did Eagles of Death
Metal that was on HBO that you're up for
an award with that 88 people died in
that terrorist 8989 at the bottle on and
there were a hundred and twenty across
Paris that night why did do you think
the terrorists decided to go into that
concert venue because it was a concert
venue that's it just because they're
just random yes there were people there
yeah I mean you can't really something
like that is just so hard to make sense
out of and you know I've known the guys
in the band for a long time now and when
you know they're the more and more you
try and think about that stuff it it
just there's no sense to it you know
it's just it's designed to be that way
it's designed to throw you off it's it's
designed to incite chaos and you know I
think you know the whole point of making
that that movie was to try and help
bring my friends a little bit of closure
to that chapter in their life and to try
and show
that you know everyone collectively
really wanted to pick each other up and
move on with their lives and you know
the sad truth of the matter is is that
you know you're not guaranteed anything
in your life my life is all you get and
really all you get is now so you guys
just got to grab as much of it as you
possibly can
is it easier or harder to do that
documentary because you're friends with
a band harder much harder it was it was
the most challenging thing I will I will
ever do hands down because it was
strange I felt like interviewing my
friends was going to be the most
challenging part and weirdly of the
process while that was incredibly
difficult that was the easiest part
because I had I was comfortable with
them and we talked a lot beforehand
about even if we were going to do it but
we talked about how honest we needed to
be with each other and how we needed to
push each other to be uncomfortable
which is not something that friends
normally do but that was necessary and
we had to go to that spot but then the
next day or two days later we ended up
flying to Paris and then I had to do the
exact same thing with about seven or
eight survivors of whom I had never met
before whom are welcomed me into their
house and they the people that we spoke
to for the film they didn't talk with
any other news outlets these people had
been hounded for three months by every
news source in the world trying to get
their story and they didn't want to tell
it because they didn't want to feel
exploited and here they were letting me
and my small crew in and asking him the
most probing questions of their lives
and in us in a second language you know
so it was it was challenging surreal
well done
thank you Eagles of Death Metal also
life in pieces season three he's Colin
Hanks and we coach I don't know if we're
gonna be able to co-star in another
movie anytime soon but I would welcome
that and hope so I'd be help you know
I'd like to help you with your career if
I can yes please
so maybe House Bunny - can I be like a
junior cop can we have like a cop buddy
show I think we could be buddy cops I
think we can we're about to
same height we're about the same height
but I'm concerned that maybe we're too
similar looking or so like one of a
handsome yeah yeah yeah dapper looking
man you're right yeah but I'm gonna have
a mustache I can look I can dumb it down
you've got range I got ray I got jim
carrey range you got jim carrey around
yes well then go ahead and put on that
Dutch I could be like in where dodged
your ass right there thank you for
coming in thank you for ever she ate
that for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]